[Music]
okay what you're about to experience is
shot in Florida a German term for taking
pleasure in someone else's misfortune
let's back up a bit
there's a cottage industry around
schadenfreude online it's why fail
videos get tens of millions of views and
it's why there's so much fun to watch
fail compilations are an evolution of
things like jackass and the America's
Funniest Home Video format which is
really just a nonfiction version of the
slapstick comedy that you see in the
Three Stooges or Charlie Chaplin movies
or Shakespeare's comedies going all the
way back probably to the origin of
laughter itself why do we feel this way
what makes us enjoy the pain of others
it comes down I think to identity and
self-esteem human society is defined by
competition and comparison when you see
someone fail your psyche is rewarded
with a little grease the feeling that
you're better off than they are shopping
for DES is particularly strong when the
failure in question is arrogant or
deserving or even just too successful
that's why we delight when celebrities
fall from grace it's why the downfall of
super-high achievers like Tiger Woods
generates so much media attention in
societies these feelings extend to our
groups the more we identify with our
in-group like our favorite sports team
for example the more susceptible we are
to schadenfreude 'ah when a rival team
loses now in the realm of sports and
people falling off rope swings feelings
of schadenfreude are natural and
innocent self-esteem is not a steady
thing that fluctuates and if a fail
compilation that makes you laugh why not
wear schadenfreude 'ah I think becomes
poisonous is in the universe of politics
I mean if schadenfreude is a feature of
in-groups and out-groups in competition
it should be no surprise that it
Fester's in our political parties where
the victory of one side almost always
means a defeat of the other and Studies
on shot in Florida in politics bear this
out intensity of party affiliation
strongly predicts weather events produce
schadenfreude in their members when the
Republican Party missteps or one of its
members commits a gaffe Democrats report
feelings of schadenfreude ah and vice
versa what complicates things is that
politics involves the well-being and the
suffering of millions of people the
failure of your opponent group can often
spell objectively bad consequences for
everybody and yet the most disturbing
finding of studies on schadenfreude and
politics is that even
in these cases people report shot in
Florida as long as their opponents lose
out scariest that is you can take solace
in the fact that most people understand
that these feelings are socially
inappropriate which is why they're felt
but not really spoken about studies bear
this out to those who report feelings of
schadenfreude at objectively bad news
like an economic downturn hurting the
opposing party are also deeply
ambivalent about just having that
emotion or at least they used to be all
I did is point out the fact that on the
cover of The National Enquirer there's a
picture of Hart him and crazy Lee Harvey
Oswald having breakfast now Ted never
denied that it was his father one of the
things that troubled me about the 2016
election was the presence of
schadenfreude among Democrats and
opponents of Donald Trump he seemed to
free people up somehow and I think it's
because ambivalence about schadenfreude
and politics is a result of the fact
that on some level we believe our
opponent group is genuinely trying to
help just going about it the wrong way
Trump on the other hand is so cartoonish
so naked ly self-serving that any
reservations people might have about
basking in his blunders just evaporated
Donald Trump is the perfect figure for
schadenfreude he checks every box
arrogant successful deserving what's
more he openly participates in it
himself
it's Rubio
Trump offered the opportunity for
guilt-free schadenfreude and this is
what troubled me because it was natural
for Trump supporters to take pleasure in
his candidacy but what I saw all around
me was his opponents feeling the same
way for many it was just as enjoyable as
watching a fail compilation video seeing
him make appalling comment after
appalling common at the start when he
was a joke there seemed to be a little
harm in expressing the schadenfreude ax
but there was an effect because the news
media registered this feeling as
interest and as a result gave an
enormous Lee lopsided amount of media
coverage to his campaign which may Trump
the focus of everything it may be the
first time in US history that collective
schadenfreude influenced a political
outcome and that's not a joke at all
right now we're living through an
intoxicating mixture of entertainment
politics journalism and schadenfreude oh
it's a mixture that is unbelievably
great through the news media and as
Trump is embroiled in the Russia
investigation the news media is showing
its best side but its worst sight - with
each new revelation each new bombshell
report the schadenfreude have become
stronger and that incentive is
impossible for media executives to
resist if Trump goes down it'll be met
with elation from certain sectors of the
public and who knows he may deserve it
but whatever happens with his presidency
schadenfreude is a drug that we ought to
keep in check because like any drug a
growing tolerance will eventually mean a
growing desire for more of it more often
and that's not a force we want power in
our politics
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching I've been thinking about this
for a while now so it was great to sort
of get it off my chest this episode was
brought to you by Squarespace if you
want to make a website and you want it
to be a really easy process Squarespace
has some beautiful award-winning
designer templates to choose from that
makes the process really simple it's got
24-hour customer service no upgrades
nothing to install no patches ever and
thinking your domain name is really easy
you can start your free trial at
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter you can get 10% off your
first purchase you want to make a
website use Squarespace thanks guys I'll
see you next time